[Music]
hello everyone I'm glad to be here it's
my first time doing a residency at the
club uh my name is aot Chandra I'm a
grandm originally from New Jersey but
currently been living in St Louis for
the last 6 seven years I'm also a member
of the slooh Colgate uh national team
which won the national championship last
year which is which is pretty cool so
yeah tonight I was just thinking we'd go
over some tactical positions and uh if
there's time at the end I'll show you uh
a full game I played which had some
instructive tactical moments as well so
let's start off with this position uh
it's it's white to play uh just think
about the position what looks off in
Black's position and what are some
motives you can exploit and then suggest
a move if you have
one and if you're in the twitch chat
feel free to share your thoughts as well
I'm keeping an eye on
that so just to get the ball rolling
Black's Knight on A5 is somewhat out of
play it's on the edge of the board and
it's currently only protected by the
queen on C7 so if we can somehow
dislodge the queen on C7
uh and undermine the defense of the n on
A5 that would be great so what are some
ways we can do
that so I'm getting some suggestions in
the chat I'll give the inperson audience
a few more minutes before we start
discussing
any ideas
anyone Bishop D6 okay Bishop D6 very
good so we're attacking the queen and
that's what a bunch of people in the
twitch chat are suggesting as well so
let's look at that Bishop D6 so we're
attacking the Queen the queen has to
stay on this diagonal in order to
protect the Knight on A5 this is d8 A5
diagonal here so he he has a couple of
choices he can either go back to d8
immediately or he can go to B6 so let's
say he goes back to
d8 so now he's stepping into into this
potential discovered attack on the def
file our Rook is lined up nicely so how
can we exploit
this I'm sorry let me get rid of
that uh yeah Bishop be for very good
sorry I drew an error which I can't get
rid of but okay Bishop
B4 we're attacking the queen and we're
hitting the Knight once again on A5 so
the knight
uh sorry the queen uh has to move and
then we pick up the Knight on A5 so we
attacked the the Knight twice and it's
only defended once so that's
nice uh Queen B6 is more tricky though
how do
we how do we uh exploit this
now so the queen is protecting the
Knight we got to keep attacking it
somehow and putting pressure on it so we
can eventually pick up the Knight on
A5 so think of forcing moves that also
create threats C5 okay it's one
suggestion does everyone like
C5 okay it seems like there's not much
disagreement so C5 so we hit the
queen Black's Queen is running out of
squares Queen to B5
still trying to protect the KN on A5 so
how do we ramp up the
pressure Rook where H which
Rook yeah very good Rook DB1 because
Rook ab1 would release the pressure on
the A5 Knight so Rook DB1 is very
accurate nice work we attack the queen
and the Rook on A1 also keeps the Knight
on A5 Under Pressure so black has to
step to the a file Queen A6 and this is
a really nasty pin
now on the A5 Knight so we're almost
there how do we wrap this up there are a
couple of moves that win we just need to
put one more attacker on the A5
Knight Queen C3 okay very good Queen C3
attacking the Knight on A5 and there's
nothing black can do about it the next
the next move we'll just pick up the
Knight some suggestions in the chat as
well Queen A3 also wins very good
attacking the Knight and Bishop C7 was
the third move so all three of those
moves win they have the same effect
attacking the Knight on A5 and black
can't do anything about that and we're
just going to win a piece on the next
move so yeah nice work uh that's it for
this position let's go to the next one I
think
it's yeah this one
so this is another one of my games the
previous one is also my game I forgot to
mention that uh all these positions are
from my games so that's a practical
element as well so in this position I'm
white I
have pretty much a winning Advantage but
it's not over yet black can still resist
uh the central uh tension favors me uh
I'm
also uh having a big advantage on the
light squares uh my Bishop on F1 is
unopposed he has no light squ Bishop he
has a dark squ bishop and he sort of
accentuated that even further by taking
on C
C4 so how do we finish the game off here
it's kind of hard to believe that the
game ends in two or three moves from
here but that's what happened and it's
all about exploiting the light squares
in the position especially around
Black's King so what's the obvious move
here after he takes on
C4 what can we start off
with Bishop
where okay yeah very good Bishop C4 so
that's check black doesn't have much
Choice has to step to
h8 so now is King's in sort of a cage
and a cocoon on the right on the king
side
so how do we how do we finish this off
Knight H4 Knight H4 are you Grandmaster
at the back
there we have Knight H4 as a suggestion
from a very esteemed
player does that look like a good move
what's the idea
Knight G6 Che very good yeah Knight G6
check and it's kind of amazing but black
has no defense against this no matter
what he plays Knight G6 is coming uh
with Queen H3 to follow so if I make a
random move let's just say this just to
demonstrate the threat Knight G6 H takes
G6 uh Queen H3 is
M so realistically the only thing black
can do to stop this is to play
G6 but that gives us other options as
well now so how do we conclude the game
here take the pawn which Pawn F6 okay
Queen takes F6 it's a check black has to
block there are few ways to end the game
here but what's the most simplest G6
check okay KN G6 is definitely a move H
takes
G6 Queen
H Queen H7 how does the queen get to
H7 H4 yeah very good and we just carry
out the same mating pattern anyways
Bishop has to block and we
take Rook takes d8 was also good enough
we just take the Rook with check and
it's going to be made anyways Rook takes
d8 Queen takes d8 bishop f8 and we just
grab the the bishop and it's
made so yeah the point this position was
just to see this idea of Knight H4 which
my opponent also missed uh it just
uh takes advantage of the light squares
uh because black doesn't have a dark a
light Square Bishop to defend so nice
job uh let's do a a harder one
uh let's do this one so this is from my
game uh in one of the classics organized
by the club I had the black pieces is
and I played Rook takes D5 here and I
thought the game was more or less over I
was going to win in a few moves because
after Queen takes D5 I played rook d8
and it seems like white has no defense
to the back rank mate coming on
D1 ideally he'd like to play something
like Queen B3 right to protect the D1
square but a takes B3 just wins the
queen that square is covered and if he
grabs my knight on E5 it still doesn't
matter I'm giving mate anyways with Rook
D1 so I thought the game was more over I
was waiting for my opponent to resign
he's down to Second as well he plays
Queen takes d8 and I was like okay big
deal I take back he still can take the
KN on E5 because there's a threat of
mate on
D1 and then he plays Rook
C3 and I had about five minutes here I
wasn't worried and I started looking at
the position and I I realized that this
is not so easy all of a sudden like what
do I even play cuz Queen D1 no longer
works he has rookie one blocking and not
only that my knight is still hanging so
he's going to take on E5 afterwards so
that's no
bueno and I can't move my knight cuz
what happens if I move my
knight uh what's the
move Rook
where like down here right yeah Rook
E8 which hits my king and queen and all
of a sudden I'm just lost like I was up
a queen and now I'm going to be down a
queen so I yeah so I can't move my
knight and queen D1 doesn't work so the
question here is now how do I how do I
untangle myself from this this conundrum
there's only one way to win and
unfortunately I didn't find it during
the game I spent all my time and and
just missed it and the game ended in a
draw a few minutes later but there's
still a way for black to win here pretty
cleanly so what's what's the obvious
move which we can start off with we
can't move the Knight can't really give
a check on
D1 but what's logical move which we can
start
with we have a hand at the
back all right let's hear
it all right we have F6 as a suggestion
also in the chat people are suggesting
F6 very good we protect the Knight so
that's obviously the first point I was
considering during the game but I
couldn't figure out what to do after F4
so he attacks my knight and he renews
the threat on it and once again the
check on D1 is empty he just blocks and
then he takes my knight
and again if I move my knight to
anywhere G4 C4 G6 anywhere no matter
what he's playing Rook E8 and winning my
queen again so once again I can't move
my knight but by playing this move F4
why do weaken this
diagonal and there's a way for us to
exploit
this it's rather tricky but it's quite
nice once you see
it okay Queen B6 that's a suggestion and
I think the chat likes that too Queen B6
so we're pinning The Rook on E3 he has
no time to you know move his king or
something because then we can then we
can move our Knight because rookie is no
longer a threat so he's got to take on
E5 and what do we play
here F5
okay and let's see I move my Rook
somewhere take the yep the rook's
hanging very good and if he takes a move
to step out of the pin take the Rook
yeah I take this Rook so no matter what
I'm winning one of his Rooks and it's
kind of embarrassing for his Rooks
they're kind of tripping over each other
so that that was the way to Victory
which I missed queen queen B6 F E5 and
F5 not the most intuitive but maybe if I
had a little more time I would have
spotted it but that's just a nice nice
way to exploit the positioning of
White's Rooks and this pin along the
along the diagonal so very good
um you guys are on a roll tonight let's
see if I can stump you
uh all right let's do this position uh
this is for my game I think in August uh
against another grand master so I played
rookie three here he was down to the
increment I had about seven eight
minutes so I played rookie three so I'm
sort of hinding at ideas with Rook E8
just to just to disturb his King and
also Rook e seven hitting
seven and my opponent blundered with
Queen to
F4 the only move for him to hold on was
King G7 but it's a difficult move in
time trouble because you know you see
moves like Rook E7 and you sort of get
scared F7 is hanging there could be
ideas with Knight E6 later because the
pawn on F7 is pinned so understandably
my opponent played Queen F4 trying to
initiate a trade of
Queens it's a common thing to do when
you're low on time as well try to try to
go for simplifications and trades to
make your job easier but unfortunately
for him this Falls prey to a to a tactic
uh it's not like a one mover or two
mover it's three or four moves so we got
to figure out how we can exploit the
back rank of Black's pieces the bishop
on B8 Bishop on C8 could be potential a
modus in the position this Rook on C5 is
also
awkward so how do we put that all
together and find a winning sequence
here
uh
yes okay so one suggestion we've gotten
is Queen takes F4
and after black recaptures Rook E8 check
that's one
suggestion do we all like that or is
there something else
else
who okay so Queen takes F4 let's look at
this it's the most natural we trade
Queens we immediately check it's all
forced which is nice black takes we
recapture King
G7 the bishop on C is protected by the
rook and C5 is there a way which we can
dislodge
it
because we'd love to play B4 but now
that the Rook is no longer on E3 oops he
takes on
C3 and all of a sudden it's probably
black who's playing for the
win uh
what
yeah so if we can't dislodge The Rook
gun C5 then it'll give black time to
consolidate his position so Queen takes
F4 doesn't quite work
unfortunately but it's the right idea
Bishop takes on D okay Bishop takes on
D5 that's an interesting idea uh Rook
takes D5 what if I take with this Rook
to keep the back rank
protected you could try something like
Rook e a check but unfortunately I'm not
obliged to take right I could just move
my king up yeah and it seems like black
has defended everything and Black's just
going to be up a piece so Bishop takes
D5 doesn't quite
work start can start with B4 okay so we
switch up the move
order there's a suggestion in the chat
G3 uh G3 it it stops black from going
Queen H2 but it's not it's not forcing
right we want to go for a tactic here
black trades queens and then he can take
a move or two to to consolidate his
position we want to go for something
forcing here so B4 has been suggested
attacking The Rook
now crucial difference here is that the
C3 Pawn is going to be protected so he
can't play Rook takes
C3 and black has no squares on the C
file to go to at the moment Rook C4 is
covered by the bishop on A2 Rook C6 also
runs into Knight takes C6 and if he goes
Rook C7 how do we punish
that that's one option but we have
something
stronger
right exactly take the girl
as someone eloquently put it Queen takes
Queen takes F4 because now the the
bishop is no longer protecting the queen
on F4 The Rook obstructs it so that
means black is forced to take on F3 and
now again we have a decision do we take
with the Knight do we take with the Rook
do we take with the pawn so what do you
guys think we should take with then
why with a
pawn why do you want to take with the
pawn we keep the pressure and
allow very good yeah perfect so we take
with the pawn so we don't ruin the
position of our Rook if we were to take
with the Rook for example we lose a big
we lose the big pressure on the E file
and move the Rook away from the action
and similarly if we take with the Knight
that also moves the Knight away from the
action the Knight is quite useful on D4
so we take with the pawn
black drops back to C7 only move for him
otherwise his Rook is
trapped so we've ruined our Pawn
structure but we've maintained the
activity of our pieces however if we
don't act fast black will consolidate
and these weaknesses on the king side
will be quite prominent so we want to
keep up the pressure with forcing moves
to keep attacking his pieces and again
look at the look at the back
rank there are a lot of vulnerable
pieces
there
okay Knight B5 that's a very forcing
move so we attack The
Rook what if I step over to the side
though okay Rook E8 but unfortunately
they don't have to take on E right they
can now they can step up with the King
because the Rook is protecting the other
rook and we can't quite get to the
pieces now unfortunately and it seems
like Black's Black's okay so it's the
right idea maybe just a little different
execution okay Rook E8 first chat also
likes Rook e eight so Rook E8 now black
has to take he's forced to take because
the Rook is still on C7 we take
back King goes up and now what do we
play very good yeah Knight B5 attacking
The
Rook if black wants to stay on the C
file he has to go up to
c65 yeah Bishop takes
D5 and the Chad is also suggesting that
as well well good job there Bishop takes
D5 and The Rook is out of squares on the
C file can't go to C7 the Knight covers
it can't go to C4 Bishop covers it and
the C3 Pawn is protected by the Knight
but let's say he tries one last attempt
Rook to B6 counterattacking our Knight
take the
bishop so his idea is if we take the
bishop he takes our Knight so that could
be good but think it through
first remember there's no need to rush
in this position Black's Bishops are in
a pretty bad
pin and again many moves win
here yeah C4 is one of them very good we
just protect the Knight and black runs
out of threats very quickly he could try
attacking our Knight but we just drop it
back somewhere let's say
C3 and there's no way for him to escape
this this deadly pin on the back rank
he's going to lose at least the piece
here and there are many ways to do this
some of the suggestions in the chat are
good too there's Rook takes C8 Rook
takes B5 C4 defending the bishop and
attacking the rook and then we pick up
the bishop
next and let's see A4 was also suggested
that's also good
just keeping everything protected and
not rushing and on the next couple moves
we'll pick up pick up one of the Bishops
on the back rank so okay that's it for
this position very well done again
doesn't seem like I'm going to stump you
guys
tonight
uh we've got I
think one
maybe yeah that might be okay one we got
one more position and then I'll go into
a game a full game I played so I'm white
here got a big space edge
obviously um control the only open D
file which is
important my pawns are also quite
Advanced here which is nice gives me
more space and Black's King is obviously
weaker than mine my king is quite safe
on G2 so in this position my opponent
rather than continue to passively defend
opted for Rook
C5 so now it's white to play how would
you react to this move
he's attacking Our Queen but we may not
be required to move
it
Rook uh Rook
where uh close yeah D7 yeah very good
okay Rook D7 that looks like an
interesting move so he attacks Our Queen
We attack his Queen back so we're sort
of um setting up a forcing sequence of
moves here all right he really has
nothing better than just take the
queen we take the queen back and he
drops back to
f8 so now what do we
do there's some complications we have to
calculate at do we go for the pawn end
game do we keep the Rooks on the board
what do we do
here we have a a pawn grubbing
suggestion Rook takes
A7 what about e takes D5 is that a move
which we should
play is this a favorable trade for us
King takes C7 doesn't seem like it right
his King comes into the game very
quickly to pick up the pawn on D5 our
King's not fast enough we lose this pawn
and we probably lose the game now so
that's no
good so after take take Rook takes A7
seems good enough right we grab a
pawn black plays Rook D3 attacking our
Pawn on C3 trying to go for
counterplay so we're up a pawn for the
moment but Black's probably going to
take on C3 and start creating
counterplay with the c
Pawn so is there a way which we can end
the game within the next few moves and
take advantage of our active rook and
his passive
King okay A5 push baby yep A5 that looks
good Chad also likes
A5 he
takes so now what do we do
the pawn on A5 Rook takes
A5 but that releases black from the
seventh the eighth rank allows him to
bring the king into the game so he can
take
here put his Rook on the B file and then
his King can come in to help we don't
want to release this king from the the
eighth rank the rook's dominating here
so we played A5 to do
what6 yeah B6 very good
exactly so A5 B A5 that allows us to
push our Pawn now
B6 black captures
pa okay we push the pawn threatening to
make a
queen Rook B3 only
move has he stopped the pawn or can we
promote
it
okay Rook eight very good check he has
to go
up yeah and then we just
promote and we win the game and one last
try for black what if he tries to stop
the pawn from
here the okay
B7 Rook
B8 Rook E8 yeah very good
The Rook comes down anyways and we're
probably going to promote the pawn in
the next move or twoo so yeah very good
um the key thing was just to realize
after Rook D7 Rook E7 King f8 we don't
rush into the pawn end game because that
would actually win for black but we just
take on A7 and see this idea with
A5 uh making way for our Pawn on the B
file and that's a typical motive when
the King is cut off and you've got a
rook on the seventh rank if you can
create a pass Pawn like that the pawn
and The Rook combo just are able to
promote
effortlessly all right so that's a good
warmup and now let's look at a game I
played um gez seven years ago has it
been that
long uh I became a Grandmaster at the
end of this tournament so this this game
was quite important it was against Jim
Ben fle whom you guys are probably very
familiar with I hope he's not watching
this don't mean to put him on the spot
but this was a very interesting game
with a with a nice finish so I thought I
had to share it so I'll just uh go over
the opening real quick does anyone know
what this position or structure is
called when you've got the C4 E4 setup
for
Whitey yeah very good maroxy bind and it
tends to be better for white because we
have more space and black can be a bit
passive but he's still very solid so
sorry it's a bit of a trade-off so
Black's trying to exchange pieces which
is typical in this
position uh because he's crammed he
wants to he wants to trade
pieces so we'll just skip over these
moves both sides are playing logical
he's developing I'm figuring out where I
want to put my pieces King H1 just a
typical prophylactic move stepping out
of Queen
B6 uh he also plays a very solid move F6
all right so I played Rook a B1 here
which is typically go for these
positions I want to play A3
B4 I couldn't play A3 immediately
because the pawn would be hanging so I
played Rook B1 oop sorry he played Rook
C8 and all of a sudden I decided to
switch gears because I realized maybe
this idea with A3 isn't isn't such a big
deal after all because even if I get in
B4 let's just make some random moves Z
B6 B4 take
take C4 Pawn could be kind of kind of a
new since it's hard to protect it now
and Knight could come to E5 hitting C4
so I gave up on this B4 idea and I
decided to switch gears I played Knight
D5 he took on D5 I guess he was annoyed
by the knight uh how should we recapture
here more of a positional
question so there are three options C
takes e takes Queen
takes uh okay queen I'm sorry okay I'm
hopeless with these arrows right so
Queen takes D5 is one idea
but Queen takes
D5 black has a very strong net on C5 and
our Bishop on E2 doesn't look so hot
right now it's behind its own pawns and
it doesn't look like it has much
potential so Queen takes D5 probably not
the best
move the E Pawn okay so what's your idea
with taking with the E
Pawn yep very good perfect we keep the C
file closed and we open up the E file
for our Rooks and all of a sudden this
Pawn on E7 is going to be very
uncomfortable it's a backward Pawn so e
takes D5 was played Black played E5
understandably he didn't want to deal
with this this potential backward Pawn
so he tries to get rid of it
immediately I took
anant he took oh sorry he played rookie
eight played F4 opening up my
Bishop potentially F3 or
G4 Rook takes
E6 improved my
Bishop black played Queen
B6 now I went for Bishop
G4 securing his Rooks he obviously
blocked with F5 and my point was to
induce that in order to throw in this
check here on the on the G file
obviously if I just go back I wasted a
move and his Knight comes into E4 and he
starts getting activity but the point is
to include this inter immediate check
take control of this diagonal and force
his King to a to an awkward Square so he
played King H6 if he goes back to
F3 I Dro My Bishop back to
F3 and all of a sudden Bishop D5 is a
nasty threat and there's no easy way to
deal with it so he played King H6 his
King is funnily enough safer on the
corner for now played Bishop
F3 and he played Rook E8 now black would
love to trade Queens here if you get the
Queens off the board it would make his
defensive task much easier especially
with that King on H6 so move like Knight
D7 would be really nice for him
unfortunately doesn't quite work yet
because I trade I actually go for the
trade and the Tactical point is rather
simple I just pick up this Pawn on B7
and he loses the pawn for nothing so he
doesn't want to defend a pawn down end
game obviously so he plays Rook e
eight question
yeah Bishop takes F5 Bishop takes F5
okay so interesting suggestion Bishop
takes
F5 F3
okay so white wants to swing his rook in
I like
your no for sure that would definitely
be better
um okay what's the best way to defend
this I don't think Bishop F5
works but how do I refute it
um I'm thinking about Rook G8 or
something which looks kind of weird but
I just want to run my king to
F7 it's like yeah like chess SL says in
the chat we are defending the G7 square
and preparing to run the king back to F7
don't really see anything right for
white check King here check he runs back
G7 square is covered and it seems like
Black's Black's
defending but of course Bishop takes F5
has to be considered because if it works
then it just wins on the
spot so Bishop F3 Rook E8 so first
critical
position uh Black's King is on the
corner of the board we have a nice
Bishop we have a nice Queen but that's
not enough to win the game we need to
bring all our pieces into the attack
unfortunately black controls the open E
file so we can't exactly play a move
like Rook E1 so what can we do to sort
of undermine the position on the king
side for
black and really expose the King on
H6 G4 very
good this move has a very nasty threat
of g yep G5 mate so G4 opens up the
position oh do it seems like I played
Bishop D5 first okay it's the same idea
probably it doesn't matter okay G4 yeah
I don't remember my own games but yeah
the the the point is that you need to
see G4 that's that's very good so
G4 he took so how do we continue plowing
forward
yep very good
F5 now black suffing a trade of Queens
because here trading queens and giving
up the B7 Pawn wouldn't wouldn't mean
much because he's already won a pawn in
G4 so he's not going to be down any
material so we want to avoid the trade
of Queens is it Queen F4 okay Queen F4
is one
idea if we play Queen F4
how does Black Block because if he goes
back he runs into stuff like fg6 or F6
so yeah G5 he
blocks and then our Queen doesn't really
have any good squares right all of a
sudden the queen has been
stymied if we take on G4 we just lost
the tempo we could have done that
immediately Knight
F6 and somehow have no useful move with
the queen all the checks are covered so
Queen F4 gives a check but G5 parries
all our threats so what should we play
instead we don't want to let black set
up a blockade around this
King okay Queen takes
G4 seems good enough right we take the
pawn back and we renew some threats yeah
Queen H4 is in the air so black plays
Knight F6 attacking your
queen
so like we said before Queen F4 doesn't
make much sense because of
G5 Queen H O sorry Queen
H4 check and hitting the Knight if he
drops back we simply take on G6 and
everything opens up in our favor he
can't take back because the knight's
hanging so he played Knight
H5 covering his King and it looks like
his King is safe for the time
being so how would you proceed with the
the attack here there's there's no
immediate win but we do want to keep his
King sort of contained on the king
side or on the edge of the board
rather okay F6 so we stopped the the
king coming back to
G7 black played Rook f8 here so Black's
idea is he needs to get rid of this F6
Pawn at all costs if he gets rid of this
F6 Pawn is doing very well his King can
always run back to G7 so if he has one
more move he wants to play a move like
Queen d8 so let's just make a a pass
move for white let's just say this this
is what black wants he wants to take
this Pawn on F6 and if this Pawn Falls
his King is safe and White's attack
doesn't look so impressive anymore and I
can't protect it by pushing it because
there's a nasty
pin so keeping that in mind we we sort
of have to understand that we don't have
all the time in the world or we sort of
have to act quick
quickly so we need to start looking at
tactical ideas around around Black's
King then not on H5 is well protected
but it could be potentially
undermined so what are some ideas here
for
white if you think about it if
we G1 yeah right if we play a move like
Rook
G1 there's a threat of madeen one it's
like almost made unfortunately it
doesn't quite work yet because what does
black play how does black
defend yeah Rook takes F6 unfortunately
by moving The Rook to G1 we lose defense
of the F6
Pawn although I'm seeing now that we
could give check and actually pick up
the Knight like this so wait maybe black
has a better defense oh yeah yes so Rook
F6 actually Rook G1 would be good if not
for Rook E5 that's the defense sorry
about that Rook takes F6 we still have
Queen G5 King G7 Queen takes H5 and
there's a
pin but there's Rook E5 which is kind of
annoying covers the G5
square and it doesn't seem like we have
any good followup here but you're on the
right track so now you know one of
Black's key defensive idea is Rook
E5 is there a way which we can obstruct
that I think someone's figured it
out
Rook B2 suggestion in the chat that's
quite interesting I see your idea you
want to play Rook G2 unfortunately this
idea of Rook E5 just stops all those
threats so for example I can go Queen d8
Rook
G2 and I don't know if I can take on F6
maybe but something like Rook E5 for
instance would be good enough for black
to defend and somehow white can break
through here
but interesting idea we have something a
bit more forceful and direct is that the
bishop Bishop
where
F3 F3 so we're trying to get rid of this
Knight on H5 it' be great if we could
take it unfortunately I think we run
into the same problem again Rook E5 this
move just keeps coming up and if we take
on H5 he takes
here we give a check he blocks G5
somehow he's holding on again and maybe
he could get some counterplay himself
with Queen C6 attacking our
King Bishop F3 doesn't quite work you
guys have all the right ideas there's
just one move that needs to be played to
make everything
work okay I think some people in the
chat figured it
out
R okay Rook F5 is has been
suggested what do you guys think of this
move does it make any sense aren't we
just giving up the
Rook okay very good so that's already an
important idea so after black takes the
line of defense has been cut off Rook e
five no longer has any
Merit but again we've just given up a
rook so we need to act
quickly so how do we follow up now
G Rook G1 very good and now we're
threatening mate on
G5 and there's no way for him to defend
he could take this pawn it doesn't
matter we give M on
G5 so in the game my opponent tried Rook
e
one which was a clever
idea seems like a random spy check but
there's a point so how should we
recapture first of all
okay Rook yeah our Queen's already doing
a good job on H4 near Black's King let's
get our last Pace into the attack G
takes F5 so it seems like it's the same
thing as the previous thing Rook G1
should be
mate but does black have a defensive
resource so Rook G1 threatening M all of
a sudden black has Queen
E3 covering the G5 Square I mean it may
still be winning I don't know but it
just becomes a mess all of a sudden and
we don't want to allow opponent our
opponent any counter playay when we're
winning so we got to keep the E3 Square
covered but maybe we don't even have to
use our Rook now maybe there are other
ideas which we can take advantage
of Bishop
where3
F3 very good hitting the Knight on H5
and there's just no way for black to
defend no matter what we're just going
to take on H5 the next move and yeah
black resigned here because it's just
the position is just completely
collapsing so yeah I thought that was a
nice finish I didn't see Rook F5
initially when I was when I was
playing
uh took me a few minutes but yeah once I
saw it I realized that okay it's just
yeah completely winning I'm not even I'm
not even sure like how winning it is if
I don't have Rook F5 because these ideas
with Rook E5 and yet are actually quite
annoying I mean black might just hold on
so yeah Rook F5 is very important but
it's good enough to to get the job
done as like yeah as like someone said
in the chat punished his never play F6
that's right that's that's why Benjamin
lost this game so yeah um I think that's
all I have uh for today's lecture if you
guys have got any questions happy to
answer them yeah actually uh you had
earlier in the in the
game you play F4 F5 yourself you played
Bishop F3 I think that was the moment
that you
play Bop was maybe on e oh okay sure
yeah
here so the um the classical rule is
when you're playing with a Bop versus KN
you should open thetion so you put your
Bishop on F3 and it's good did you
refuse F5 yeah sure that's a great
question so the question here is why did
I not play a move like F5 here it seems
very natural I'm opening up the position
for my Bishop I didn't like it though
because it gives up the E5 Square
something like Rook E5 and I wasn't sure
how to evaluate this I mean so you take
on G6 I could take on G6 H takes G6 and
then this rook in
E5 as you sure uh Queen E7 Maybe
sure Rook B1 Rook
d8 give me the
pawn I didn't even see that yaser is
impeccable instincts for pawns Queen
takes A5
sorry Instinct that's that's nice yeah
that that wins a pawn so seems like I
have to actually worry about that
uh so what if I play the way he did in
the game I play like Queen B6 or maybe
let's say even Queen C7 to keep the pawn
protected and maybe
prep it's more of
a
question like here you could play as in
the game
vis5 your Rook is open on the F5 and it
was like you decided to keep PS on
F6
for a specific reason and here I was
just wondering why with the bishop you
would
play yeah I just felt like the time
wasn't right for that yet and giving up
the E5 Square was was probably favorable
to Black at this current moment like as
we played in the game with Bishop F3 I
thought something like this would be
would be more desirable to provoke him
to play F5 to set up ideas with G4
somehow giving up the E5 Square
especially in the Sicilian I'm always
hesitant to do do that I mean if there's
a concrete reason like like you
suggested then I'm open to it but I
think yeah F5 Rook E5 makes his
defensive task a bit easier for the
moment but it could be just a personal
preference also
yeah right
yeah anyone else have any questions or
from the chats anyone want to ask me
something about this game or any of the
other positions we looked
at
got another question from yaser how is
Doha so I'm being asked how was Doha
it's in reference to a tournament I
played uh a couple of days ago it ended
the guitar Masters it was a strong open
tournament headlined by former world
champion Magnus Carlson my tournament
itself was okay I broke even at the end
got some brutal pairings playing a bunch
of underrated Asian kids which is never
fun but overall I can complain plus one
in a strong tournament is is pretty okay
so the the ride back was definitely
exhausting though wouldn't recommend
that what did you think of the analog
watch
controversy that's a juicy question uh I
honestly don't really know what what the
issue was like he was just wearing his
watch and adjusting it constantly I
don't know it seems like uh there was
much to do about nothing there except
for the rule that you can't bring in
your own Pen watch yeah I I didn't know
that was a rule but I guess that's up to
the organizers to enforce it they
probably should have done that from from
round one but I don't think it had any
bearing on the game I mean white just
punished a bad game from black yeah
actually we're really going to need your
hot take on this issue and we're going
to clip it we're going to all over out
of context
yeah really juicy head yeah that that
sounds
good thank you
so yeah thanks guys for coming out
appreciate it uh enjoyed the interaction
with you and to those in the chat also
good job you guys suggested a bunch of
great moves so happy about that uh I
guess guess we're done now sure all
right good
[Music]
night